[Music]  do you know why the Phoenix fits on the  right hand at the Opera she is his  guardian his protector that she supposed  people and strong your job is to bring  honor to the family do you think you can  do that  citizens we are under attack from  northern invaders their leader calls  himself Oricon fights alongside of which  no survivors  by eating of his Imperial Majesty every  family must contribute one vow to fight  a few no son I am blessed with two  daughters I will fight  you must be strong this time you will  not return loyal brave and true  it is my duty to protect my family  [Music]  and sisters please protect her  what is your name soldier watch you in  commander son of war Joe we're gonna  make men out of every single one of them  the spirits is evident something holds  you back  when they find out who you are they will  show you no mercy  I'm home alone I will bring honor to us  all  [Music]